for me i think a real fighting is not
really like this my name is called
srianzu
shenzhe is the shaolin temple name
since 1983 i went to shaolin
temple so i'm now i'm the 34th
generation shaolin
kung fu warrior disciple in 1998
i came to london my traveling experience
you know is more than 35 years today i
will
break down some kung fu movies
when we talk about what you teach they
say we teach shaolin
but because charlene is so big people
really hard to recognize
what is the shaolin style look like
because charlene you know they have
a hundred hundred different forms and
also weapons and also the training 72
styles
for my opinion so it says shaolin style
basically
is the kung fu and the wisdom together
so it's balanced the mind body spread
balance
he come here try to fly jump to him then
hit straight away no we don't need
you see he don't need to some fancy moon
he's even he just lie down on the floor
they give you one girl and give you one
kick this is simple
for much what is the useful is beautiful
useless
you know on a fancy you know i don't you
know i don't think it's a build
beautiful
kung fu kicks you know they have they
have many kicks
we have a
and also we have backspin high kick
now sweeping have a fun sweeper back
sweep
also flying kicks flying knees
so all the different types kicks
in in matraz pancho is the same as well
punch they have
[Music]
they have some chinese name one also
they use
like a boxing one one is a straight
punch and also you have a
hook punch and also they have a uppercut
but they're just called a jutran by
trent
guccian also they have another different
one it's like a back spin so
when you're fighting sometimes you do
one and you back a spin
kick a punch you do that one you back a
spin also they have to
they use here to fight yeah fight and we
call the bien trench
is like a snap like i use them uh
one rope just snap like this so
this this punch is very powerful
now this could try to side kick troy is
very
famous chinese tradition kicks
also this bruce lee i think is a
favorite kick
in the film you know this sidekick a lot
of power
[Applause]
he learned from the wind tune you know
that's the regular
really representing tifa about the wind
train styles
and he gives the chinese name about this
called go low show
the generator push you and you they feel
you push back
then your hands come back then because
you push
to me then i come to fight you it's like
a
uh crashed that's why the
in the film they they're doing this one
if you have the back flip you know this
skill you practiced
then you can he's trying to tell
the people in different situations what
type of technique
you use you can see they grab the leg
and already lift up in that time then
you go to
back a spin into this kick it's a
i think it is possible for the easy way
if you grab on my leg and
one leg there so i can punch you
and whatever i just quickly push you on
the floor and beat you
you know that's the in reality this
probably is most useful one
bruce lee film you can see they they
called many many
millions people to learn the martial
arts
i watched this film under 1983
i went to charlene you can see they have
a
lot of different weapons but normally we
should have 18 different
styles different weapons so in here you
know i think at least they have
eight or nine or ten they have a stick
they have a spare they have a sword
they have a three section chain
and also they have two sections one this
one is like a one
it's a side lung another and on the top
they have this
lung with a chain
you know when you use a stick even you
use a spare because it's long weapons
you can you you that's that is quite
useful technique
because if many people they try to close
to you you're holding
in the middle and you use your waist
you're touching with you're turning
see then this side they become powerful
this side they become powerful
they can hit people the men is they
don't want the people out close to him
yeah you want to make a big swing or
whatever so the people
will go hiding or go back so you have a
space
when you use long weapons you need to
have a space you don't have a space you
cannot fight
now that's the one pull me go to shaolin
temple
for me as a real fighting is not really
like this
what happens someone face to you they
want to fight you
so simple you know this question you
keep giving punch or giving kick
you don't make some posts and whatever
so it's this is just
for film for show and that post you know
huang fi hong kong league films they
made this this post
that posted regular straight away i see
it's confession
another other one is like it can be the
crayon or the taiji
you know styles like that yeah they do
have um
look like that makes them many styles
in there even you know they're doing
you know and this this they have shaolin
have this kind of auto body have this
kind of movement as well because it's
really powerful
the house will have bruce lee styles but
i really don't have bruce lee movement
you know the
bruce lee movement is really easy to to
to recognize
i heard you know he's doing this from
his spanish six months to training
so for six months to get this kind of
the acting
like this is quite good you can see the
energy is there so the
if they really put a time to training
you know real kung fu they can be they
both can be very very good
chinese kung fu film they really like to
show some incredible
results to to people who can see you
kung fu how good
they fly and they go the knee to the
floor and the wooden floor have big tent
so you don't need a see he do any fancy
movement
just that one he's already told that guy
is very good
kung fu kung fu fighting is not like
that at least you know in qatar five
jackie chan the style is a different is
like for street fight
for one fight many people he's very very
good
action kung fu films it's quite
real it's funny and brother is real for
example like here that is the closing
hanging
because he can use chairs can use
anything to
to against especially one person fighter
many people
and also he's very flexible as well
you fight the left the guys and the
writer god coming you can see he
he he knows so he go there quickly sort
out
then he'll have to go there he cannot
keep going like this don't care ah
guy in reality if you really meet these
bad situations
for somehow and you like put your life
in danger
and you have experience you know to
fight and you cannot run away you have
to
so then these different stories uh
jackachand the styles
these people need to study you know you
can see they run
they fight some place they cannot run
they find a business place so you know
it's a
big window or whatever bigger fans you
cannot claim then they have to
fight in shaolin we also churn in
sometimes returning one fighter two one
fighter three
one fighter five in reality if they're
holding holding something they don't all
come together they come
too close they can hit each other as
well
i think this kick is a uh
is architect but if they really have a
powerful
than is possible because you can see
they they're holding the
closing hanging bar and they're kicking
like this so in the realized reality we
see
many people like this we punch even into
one punch they can fly
do one kick is same
[Applause]
that can happen if really powerful that
can happen
like this normally you know so they that
the opponent they they help each other
for example when i hold the one the
jacket chain holds his leg other guy
they their two legs
he tried to hold his waist clench
more harder so it makes him easy to to
swing
if reality if he want he also can
in reality if i hold your leg like this
doesn't matter your leg
loose or not i just use this pickup then
i can swing you
as well i think his point is quite high
for me i think
even like 8-9
the king of the weapons is a spare
and because of the king weapons that's
why because very difficult to palace
very difficult to make a high
achievement then top of the spell
you know you go to stop you know it's
like a
arrow shooting so and very fast very
direct
very powerful it's hard to block very
hard to block
especially when they use this technique
you know we called our language
that means block na means control
jar means stop when we practice the
spare in the shaolin
the master teach only are standing here
holding the stick just holding the spear
just keep
doing this movement
so many times that sometimes the master
just
saw the tree they have a tree they said
that one leaf so you go to stop
the leaves leave the tree leaves they
just yeah
you know it's even ten times you cannot
reach one in the film you show that kind
of skill
it's not easy to get the sword they have
all different technique
for example if you're holding the salt
in here
so people use a spare to attack you you
go under you see then it's been blocked
so once you blocked then you can use
your sword
to chop him to attack and also they have
one hand is free but if the spares stab
me so
i go like that i go like that so then i
can use my hand you see
grab yeah so i'm do very fast i go
if you for example if you go here
and then another guy is coming
doing something so when you go here so
you you blocked
and you have to quickly you go down so
that's why the
the thoughts they have a very important
the basic movement
we call the chanthog channel basically
is your
head they use for example this is the
sword they go from here
go to your head come back come hit up
for me behind your head
then come to here they have two ways one
is like this
two is like that opposite way come back
this is a basic movement
when you learn the sword kung fu is not
only fist
or legs going for weapons as well
yeah man he he's acting the he's a
win-twin master
another guy you know hong kimba also
he's a kung fu master
that's the stories that try to test his
wing chun style how good it is
so then the two use the different type
of the
traditional kung fu the store
his stuff his his leg and just jump a
fly to that you see that
this already show you know incredible
skill
you know i think is it for sure how good
they are
all my life i never see some fight like
this of course they're doing
mostly the wind train you can see the
windshield like this the batch
you know the batch you know in bajirao
batch
also in shaolin have shiny also they
have this kind of technique
this fight we don't they are both is a
traditional kung fu they are both
but just different style
now this movement this kick is portable
but in here if they don't use the wires
they're doing that afterwards we don't
know maybe they fall down
yeah maybe they just fall over on the
table
it's very difficult very dangerous
if i on a table fight and i try to stay
in the middle
you know i make my stance bigger it's
more stable so i put you in the age
so you need to come in and just give one
kick you just off a table
this is simple yeah but you know
so in in this one probably they're doing
uh
fairly you know also it's a very fancy
and dramatic
used age eye stage you know you move
forwards i move forward
so i this means i i respect
each other he's very skilled he's great
fighter
and his real fighter as well so he like
doing real action give you one kick not
a hundred percent power
no at least it's 70 80 percent power so
when we do some film training you know
we're doing some
uh actions you know even people punch
like this acting you punch you block
this you block that
normally we don't you kick your block or
die blocker
second day you see there some hair is a
little bit bruised
there the bruise for the action film you
still need to take
people power otherwise still look like a
fake on the table fight
i don't think it's a reality nobody
fight on the table
[Music]
even they don't have weapons just empty
hands
actually he can you see they have a lot
of chance you can get a sword
or can get a spare but it looks like i
just know interesting
it's not everyone come to fight him
together
only despair you can see despair you
know many people from
far away all despair to come to attack
him
to kick if you clog the ladder you you
just
point to their place then jump the kick
then it's possible
[Music]
this technique is possible to break the
stick
because he used his leg you know while
rub around like a snake
to fight a lot of people you know with
other weapons
i don't think is is possible certainly i
think an
action film the kung fu film he's a very
good acting he's a
world champion you know the usual
champions
means seven different face reform and
different weapons you know and also
the fight they got a seven champion this
is not a real fight you know so i i
for the real one i don't think you know
this is only choreography
there is like a cartoon or something you
know so
when they kick in whatever people fly
then you see that
it's too much i think it's like a fun
it's fun
film for people
chinese essential they do have some
grabbing leg
skill but because
you cannot over over spin his foot
because he overspin
his foot and the joint will be broken if
on the street fighting you want to break
his
leg and also that guy the opponent is
very experienced
if you hold his leg you want to twist
the over twist
in a 360 angle to break his knee it's
possible he will do the spin
you can do set two kicks in reality you
know you can do in different
way but they use very uh
clever enough strategy you know you can
do one fake kick
then on one real kick you can do one
sweep kick then you just
nearly fall down and give you one knee
or give you one kick they do once
lightly control sweep kick and kick him
make him lose like that
and he's kicked and his foot come back
and boom give you a second kick
because this one they have a handle
however so it's uh
it's easy and it's more easy than the
than the knife
everyone have this you know called a
foothold
photobang is uh they have a foothold
that's called axe caller foothold
they're not just throwing they just keep
doing like that so you
you know hold properly otherwise they
will lose
really they don't it's not useful
not difficult his disorder is much
heavier than
than the monks one so
in that point you know so if he used
that and then you use
this tool against it's possible to break
they they too holding the sword two
different types of salt
one is not a very wide one it's called a
grid
dough goes the head salt
and the monk with soda is quite common
in china
they just go through from the thoughts
you know so
it's been basically they know their life
is ending this is the exact
talk about the justice against the evil
time you know so when you know it's time
to death
then you just just dead for the
meaningful
things so sometimes the kung fu is not
who is the best skill you know is who is
the best person
you know it's a spirit the old action
kung fu film
is trying to spread out the message it's
the justice
is the peace for the real martial artist
the spirit when you
face to some situations if you know it's
a time to
die then you you go to it you know for
example to protect the people
to protect the peace they're good i
can't give you even now i can give like
this full point you know it's 10 because
they talk the
truth you know the truth is there
see he got a hit you know two punches on
his face
saying bruce lee his acting you know
that also is quite
good quite like a reasonable like a
reality
it's not only you beat someone else and
you're never getting beat
they showed his the willpower the spirit
you can see his eyes his
energy you know they try to show their
best
skill it's very good we watched
his fighting even look like this century
in that time martial attack i think the
real traditional martial arts
is most people doing the films and also
the fighting never see some fighting
like this
so he's like a genius man
when i was young in charlene i have his
book
and i read a lot now we know about his
stories he'll have some experience of
karate
he's doing with taekwondo doing with the
boxing
afterwards he got up so and i calm down
you know he changed the techniques
for me you know he's my hero he's my
teacher you know so
it's really for me to to judge about to
say about something like this
opinion is you know for me he's
ideally you know the man you know he's
number one you know
if we say the score you know of course
it's full of the score
it's like a cartoon or something you
know so
when they kick in wherever people fly
then you see that
it's too much i think it's like a fun
it's fun
film for people